by the way you mentioned that was that
your son made a drawing in the
background to help promote the show and
he seems orange glasses and hook for a
hand used you with some sort of scary
stories to tell in the dark type
situation yeah I love that I love that
orange glasses and a hook for a hand is
what I mean - your son yes you must be
yet you must be you must be a God in
your home because you did something you
took part in a very special Sesame
Street and you got to talk to Elmo on
Zoom I did that must have been huge for
your kids
it was great I basically was like well
after we film a segment can my kids talk
it was amazing I mean my my kids just
you know he's so real to them and my
two-year-old he's got maybe one brand he
recognizes in his life and it's like
elbow was the first word he said really
clearly before mommy and daddy he was
like Elmo put on Elmo so like talk to
Elmo and Elmo gives him a thumbs up and
he gives a thumbs up it was really it
was really awesome it's amazing when you
have those moments where also your kids
are probably looking at you and thinking
wait you're our connection to Elmo you
must have achieved something in this
life I know trust me I know I know it
doesn't it doesn't get it lasts for
about 5 minutes it doesn't it doesn't
get you anything at all